50 minutes by Delhi pops oh oh Fox in
open court is the other springboard
[Applause]
the LaMarcus Aldridge first has their
starting team back here Murray takes
Rizzo right to the cup and scores even
with the rebound
fox look go look at the ball he talked
about electricity
look at that move and back all this time
you don't like NBA basketball this put a
clock on it it's wake right down the
lane with no help there because of the
transition there's the 22 year old
Murray with the steal and the slam
there's a second team all to thunder he
DeAndre Aziz came up the floor to the
upgrade you really can't have a better
guy than that there's pops and he now
makes it 65 34 cycle a little left hand
dribble right hand spin in the right
hand box with a steal
bucks guys can do that and the earrings
box electrifying everyone here that
would be look at that put some cheese
and bacon on that oh baby earth box
nicely done
left-handed scoop Pass just throw it out
fully handle the beer he's found the
light grant oh oh oh my goodness did we
just see pops jump up and block that
shot by Jackson get it done inside think
you got it point-blank
thank you very much we're going the
other way look at mr. box up the bug 210
[Applause]
how about the Aaron Fox right here grin
he is feeling all Michael Jackson just
beat it baby oh goodness gracious and
those are the type of plays that get the
King started the fans are standing on
their feet they'll keep that play in
mind if things turn around here in the
second quarter the Aaron Fox it's for
the guy with the ball right now that
this what does he has four assists yes
he is leaving the park finish and guess
what he now has two parts
taking it up top look at this grant turn
the corner up top women I do I deliver
baby you gotta wrap him up 108 103 if
you don't like that you know that can't
be a basketball Oh delivers whoa another
contact here 10 on the clock box box
spinning box into the lane like that you
don't like keeps basketball oh boy we'll
go the other way
Jackson three-on-two box box
oh if you don't like that you know like
Kings basketball the Aaron Fox
just don't jump this what they say yeah
yeah a little taunting six to seven
hundred threes a day you put that
together about 45
now not a good start to this 30 quarter
but look at that block by D Aaron Fox
and somebody's jumped you see get his
feet together and then let me beat it
like Michael Jackson against the
backboard he says Wow whoo you know
first of all you just talk about the
effort
[Applause]
it was a very difficult fast let's take
another beautiful pass by foxes but
you're right do you think knock down
some pressure shots right so turn the
corner deep bench by Buddy hield Hank
the Aaron Fox oh boy well with the
contest
listen heard the all the way over here
grant I love it and here he is speaking
of defense in a steel box for five with
the lead
[Music]
eight lead changes ten ties box goodbye
you're a slam dunk contest only waiting
you give them here here give him
[Applause]
at basketball play four seconds away box
box spinning full length of the court
move bite the Aaron Fox half with 14
points five assists and you can see that
the ball was can't expect them to shoot
the same percentage movie as they did in
the first half which was incredible
oh what a pass how about the Aaron Fox
getting that ball I had the buddy here
and creativity on the flop the second
time you seen this right here though you
haven't seen this one before that was
just right on the money to put a year
opportunity to shoot the three-ball
instead watch the challenge and then
with the kind of breaks also be wiring
bow
that's the top speed the Aaron Fox is on
fire confidence that we're seeing out of
the air a little pump fake go no I won't
go
will do is drop you off right here in
our 11th bad pass
Minnesota numbers box says note I got it
box box wow what a nice see
Aaron Fox that's playing center field
right there grant give me that closing
speed is what I call it and I not only
close it I deliver mr. Troy Williams yep
is he fun to watch about pops twisting
weaving firing and didn't understood the
elite side box steps on the gas pedal
box continues and set the PUD alive the
Aaron Fox its navigating traffic like he
is out on the Autobahn delivers at the
basket grants last year he was not able
to make these type of plays look at the
pump that he takes right there creates
the contact delivers at the basket you
know like Kings basketball from Kentucky
has ten good first quarter in the books
29:28 Memphis your hands make sure you
protect the ball as much as possible as
you see you stand turn the ball over
all right numbers and there it is how
about that healed in Fox playing catch
five flying in for the slam dunk
and what would you call that is that
that would be attacking the basket sir
like no there's nobody in front of you
go ahead
Oh baby see now Beto Nance fading away
off the side of the backboard for on Fox
bull and a steam into the lane and he
takes it all the way open court takes a
look around checks his rearview mirror
goes down he'll deliver that
domestically with the right hand slapped
away the elites into the floor oh look
at that pass by Fox to Buddy hield
that's incredible I think yes good hands
fighting here and any just beautiful
pass up foot box he's arrived here in
the third dear and box with a triple out
put them on skates get a movement stop
down a few seconds box to the lane oh
man he showed Romani was gonna shoot it
I'm getting to the paint babies black
shot pop stays with it dumps 4945 we're
gonna talk about working you blocked my
shot denied rate that's okay here comes
the screen
[Music]
good defense on Luca three-pointer and
as Paul says Donna
[Music]
box here and [ __ ] like I said grant
that's the difference right there look
at the file that right here we see the
mastery of the Friday that they have
Bougainville gana [ __ ] and I'm on
Shumpert boxes they're gonna need it and
there's box banking at home let us paint
it around here they give fox a little
space and he scores at the pusher
he'll just did outrun balls yeah I mean
if it you got it
but he said you got it Lilly says I got
it see toes apart evading firing no good
well that's good Sacramento defense in
this era with cauley-stein a good bonus
right there cuz he could stay in front
of see you later David Baca rebounds one
assist the line the Aaron Fox
[Applause]
what do you call this right here grant
this is called body control delivering
offensively so you got to continue to
lock down and make some make some shots
at this thing if we see the errand go
inside and just strong move by mr.
Popham right here just read the baseline
drive comes inside strong moves by me
here and right there
Devonte Graham back in kidd-gilchrist
will come out with 39 seconds left to to
shoot box sees it beats the clock and
scores slithery box right there it's
right through and delivers with a layup
or four Lillard and he throws it away
another Portland turnover Fox
[Applause]
got to have it yes sir yes sir
faculty starting this third quarter with
Coley Stein and Shumpert oh boy good
start and a chance for a three-point
play
that is a beautiful right there you
watch this beautiful pass by B Aaron Fox
season driving man good defense dear
crown knocked away by Fox call the Stein
and the Kings come up with it let's see
if they can convert nice passing
beautiful basketball and it's a 68 to 65
game quick outlet numbers an easy basket
to make it 63 44 see if you're hearing
right here after the defense body King
shovel pass up top shot but we are
talking about the un-fun yes read our
[Applause]
the ends the first half with the king is
leading five for 55 to 38 it's over the
top athleticism adding three ball now
just blast by jacks demolishing the
sun's defense
there's Johnson an incredible play by
the Aaron Fox it would just made the
best get at the other end
[Applause]
holy [ __ ] chief with nowhere to block
the shot first half on a high note they
have played very well in this first half
of play basket is good by your point
guard box 13 1 prepend it's nice down
there I'm just saying I have a problem
with that right no glowing green I don't
want to hear it job is trials 70 to 60
grievance is going to take a timeout
Celtics with the lead for 23 left here
in the phone not going to get too many
more opportunities
[Applause]
[Music]
pitch to it he cheats on the way down is
there that's never good right don't know
it is nurse box he shoots on the way up
and he makes back-to-back we don't want
them to get downhill on you because they
can deliver at the basket oh wow there
is a missile going through msg right
there how quick was that bird watch that
box comes down the back knee well here
looks like Brunson's going to get it but
the airman says not mean if he can just
spot up and make shots he can be very
driver
oh you don't like that you don't like
NBA basketball the Edward Fox Fox now
just explore hoops past the first one
[Applause]
could have to hurry here box boots to
fly boy was that Clutton what to pass
out by Willie and the clock running down
here is the errand boss flashy I mean he
had to do something and he did Daniels
is coming what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content